foreign
on this Friday night the mess and the
misery from two tornadoes people in
Ontario and Quebec pick up the pieces
half of Loops has gone there how the
nation's capital could be more
vulnerable to Violent weather the
struggle to find affordable housing
we've got students who are living in
their vehicles how the cost of rent has
hit the roof the buzz over the caffeine
in Prime energy drinks some advice to
parents plus we reality check the who's
Declaration on aspartame being possibly
carcinogenic and astronomical shifts
how humans thirst for groundwater has
knocked the Earth off its axis
[Music]
global national with paranasser
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us a
major cleanup is underway in parts of
Southern Ontario and Quebec tonight two
tornadoes ripped through the region one
in Ottawa the other just north of
Montreal officials are tallying the
damage but it is extensive Fierce winds
tore siding off of homes and flash
flooding swamped streets the severe
weather may have settled for now but as
Korea Israel reports researchers say
intense storm fronts are becoming more
frequent and are shifting East
rebuilding will likely take weeks after
a tornado lasting just seconds the
entire roof is gone just Rafters are
left and all the insulation was you know
ripped out of there a fierce storm
rolled into Ottawa and ripped through a
suburb in the city's Southwest this man
was at home with his family when it
struck just screamed everybody to hit
hit the basement my daughter was up in
her room at the time the tornado damaged
more than a hundred homes tearing off
the sides of houses smashing windows and
sending shingles into the air if I saw
damage inside the roof from the hole the
half of roots has gone right so that's
that big damage
construction crews are trying to make
homes livable again this was actually
really bad yeah it wasn't your standard
wind storm so any house that has damage
for the most part A lot of the plywood
and insulation's actually been ripped
off and blown out as well downed trees
are scattered on front yards across the
neighborhood as City Crews try to clean
up the huge mess left behind
on the same day a separate tornado
slammed into a Montreal suburb it wasn't
wind but water causing the bulk of the
problems thunderstorms Unleashed A
month's worth of rainfall on the city in
just two hours stranding drivers and
backing up sewers from this corner we
had to run up to our knees to get to our
house the storm left thousands of people
without power flooded homes businesses
even this shelter sadly the damaged side
we had two feet of water in our basement
and uh for us what this means is just as
an awful lot of waste
tornadoes flooding and wildfires this
summer has been especially severe
climate change and population growth are
putting new pressures on Canadian cities
there's more density there's more stuff
than there are more impacts another
change researchers say the national
capital region is becoming a tornado
alley before we were seeing that the
peak tornado area was the southern part
of Saskatchewan there but we've been
finding it's shifted eastwards and a
shift in strategy may be what's needed
to make cities more resilient as Fierce
storms become more frequent
Global News Ottawa
a 19 year old Wildfire fighter has died
in the line of duty in Southeastern BC
police say Devin Gayle was working with
a team clearing brush near Revelstoke
members of her team lost contact with
her and then found her caught under a
Fallen Tree the crew began first aid
before she was airlifted to hospital
where she died revelstoke's mayor says
the community is in shock
devastated
um you know we we think about anyone
who's who's trying to protect our
community and and whether there's an
injury or in this case tragedy with loss
of life is just devastating for all of
us
a number of agencies are now
investigating Gail's death including the
RCMP and the BC coroner service in the
United States more than 90 million
Americans were placed under some kind of
heat advisory today as a Relentless Heat
Wave blankets more than a dozen states
forecasters wore an all-time records
could be broken in the southwest this
weekend with temperatures expected in
the mid to high 40s in Phoenix Arizona
daytime temperatures have now remained
above 43 degrees for two straight weeks
with little relief overnight conditions
are also expected to intensify in the
Northwest and much of the Southern U.S
over the weekend
a judge has granted a temporary
injunction to remove a blockade at the
Brady Road landfill in Winnipeg
protesters have until six o'clock
tonight before police move in the judge
says they can stay at the site but they
can't block the road the barricade was
set up last week after the Manitoba
government said it would not fund a
search of the Prairie green landfill for
the remains of Morgan Harris and
Mercedes Myron to missing and murdered
indigenous women
five months ago a terrifying scene
unfolded at a shooting range in Langley
British Columbia it ended with a police
officer taking his own life the
horrifying incident followed a
months-long investigation of the officer
for breach of trust now with Catherine
urquhart reports court documents in the
case have been unsealed by a judge
in February Surrey Police Service
Constable dilbag Dylan hote took his own
life while at a shooting range in
Langley it happened as the former Mount
he was facing a breach of trust charge
following months of Investigation into
his behavior details of the
investigation have been largely unknown
as court documents were sealed but now
following a court challenge by global
news a judge has unsealed the search
warrants and affidavits allowing us to
report why he was facing a criminal
charge court documents reveal that in
August 2022 a 15 year old girl filed a
report with Suri RCMP saying she had met
hote amid a search for her missing
friend she said she had identified
herself to hoti as being 15 years old
and that after initial text messages
hoti asked to transition to his personal
cell phone she said he asked her to meet
with him late at night and had engaged
in conversations about consuming alcohol
telling her he gets wild and horny when
he drinks and told her he wanted to meet
at 10 to 10 30 pm and said they would
play Truth or Dare in person something
she had initially suggested the girl's
cell phone data was extracted by
investigators two days later hoti was
arrested his two cell phones seized
along with his notebook his service
revolver was also taken and he was
suspended it was a breach of trust
investigation that was being fronted by
Suri RCMP and was working its way
through BC prosecution Services
investigators haven't confirmed if hoti
was about to be charged criminally when
he shot himself at the range search
warrants are providing some insight but
many questions remain in connection with
the case and the allegations which
remain unproven Catherine urquhart
Global News
interest rate hikes and new listings are
said to have had a cooling effect on
Canada's hot housing market last month
pushing the Real Estate Association to
cut its home sales forecast for this
year and next the Crea says some 460
thousand properties are forecast to
trade hands in 2023. that's nearly a
seven percent decline from last year and
much larger than the one percent decline
the association predicted three months
ago the 2024 Outlook was also lowered in
the industry group's latest report it's
now expecting just over 510 000 home
sales next year a drop from the more
than 560 thousand previously predicted
prices however aren't expected to fall
anytime soon as a lack of Supply is
still hampering several major markets
across the country it's not only
affecting buyers but renters who are
struggling to find affordable housing
options this week saw yet another record
high with average asking rents in Canada
hitting more than two thousand and forty
dollars a month up more than 10 percent
from last year Heather urich's West
reports
thank you
international student Luis Sanchez is
trying to refocus on his studies it's
been a difficult few weeks trying to
find a place to live I started looking
out outside of campus and it was a
really difficult task because the prices
have gone up significantly over the past
year even with the addition of a
roommate the fourth year political
science student will be paying several
hundred dollars a month more still he
feels lucky to have found a place at all
we've got students who are living in
their vehicles temporarily who have
lived in their vehicles temporarily
because they couldn't find a place to
live and that's just not okay in a place
like Calgary across the country the
situation is even more challenging in
June the average rent for a one bedroom
in Calgary was sixteen hundred eighty
seven dollars compared to over 2500 in
Toronto or nearly three thousand dollars
in Vancouver we need to increase the
supply of housing in May the Prime
Minister told a conference of Big City
Mayors that four billion in federal
funding will be coming to help cities
increase their housing Supply but with
interest rates Rising Advocates say
vulnerable families need help now we
have seen over the past year a doubling
in
um calls for help from families families
telling us that they can no longer
afford their rent or their mortgage
they're facing eviction Luis Sanchez is
thinking of his future as well
originally from Mexico the student was
hoping to stay in Canada after
graduation now he and his classmates
aren't so sure I really have heard
stories of other students that are
thinking of even moving to the United
States after they graduate because the
cost of living in terms of Housing and
overall uh life it's cheaper than in
many Canadian cities the weight of both
an affordability and housing crisis just
too much to take Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
escaping Russia's War coming up time is
running out for ukrainians to apply to
stay in Canada plus why Ukraine wants a
weapon other countries including Canada
have banned
Canada's emergency Visa program for
ukrainians fleeing the war is set to
expire applications for expedited visas
and temporary residency permits are
closing Saturday the federal government
says it has helped tens of thousands of
ukrainians fleeing Russian aggression
even as we sunset this particular
immigration program which was a
temporary program Canada will continue
to stand resolved behind Ukraine with
our NATO allies
more than 800 thousand visas have been
approved ukrainians have until March
31st 2024 to arrive and they can stay up
to three years it's unclear whether the
government will offer long-term Refuge
it appears Russian President Vladimir
Putin is distancing himself from the
private military group once so critical
to his war on Ukraine Putin says the
Wagner group simply does not exist last
month they turned on Russia and staged a
brief armed Mutiny it also has fought
some of the bloodiest battles since the
War Began more than 500 days into the
invasion Ukraine says it's making slow
progress as Crystal gamanzing Reports
cluster Munitions could help their
counter-offensive
it's the first image of evgeny progosian
since he led a mutiny heading towards
Moscow the post on the telegram app says
the Wagner head is in Belarus the
private mercenary group is training
belarussian soldiers but it's likely
they'll also keep fighting in Ukraine
Vladimir Putin told a Russian newspaper
despite the Revolt he offered to let
Wagner mercenaries continue fighting as
long as progosian wasn't involved
Ukrainian President says at the moment
there is no large-scale threat from
Belarus and that full concentration is
on the front
ukrainians are trying to reclaim
territory in the south and east but
Russians are said to be well protected
in deep trenches surrounded by fencing
and mines
for the ukrainians to gain any grounds
push the Russians back they have to go
through these incredible defenses that
have been set up three four five or six
different lines that's where these come
in
cluster Munitions could come into play
they're now in Ukraine's possession
courtesy of the U.S both Russia and
Ukraine have used these rounds in the
past they hold lots of smaller
explosives that are released midair and
fan out some don't explode right away
more than 100 countries have banned them
including Canada and the man who
shepherded the 1996 land mines treaty is
outraged once you unleash the dogs of
war you're never sure where they're
going to run to well I think we've
Unleashed this whole issue of using
these terrible weapons in fighting off
invading Russian forces Ukraine has been
using an estimated 8 000 rounds a day
the United States are supplying those
cluster Munitions is that we we
collectively the West can't Supply
Ukraine with enough conventional
artillery shells the way it could have
been avoided is that Mr Trudeau and
other NATO leaders had grown the spine
earlier to to send Ukraine the muscle it
needed and the grinding protracted War
isn't likely to end soon
Crystal gemancing Global News London
new concerns about caffeine and
aspartame ahead should you be changing
your habits
it has been a busy week in health news
late yesterday the World Health
Organization labeled aspartame as a
possible carcinogen on top of that
Canadian authorities have recalled
several caffeine-filled energy drinks
joining us now to help put this all into
perspective is David ma professor of
human health and nutritional Sciences at
the University of Guelph so first of all
can you give us some context around the
who's report on aspartame and the
recommendations
thank you for having me so the who
report basically tells us that in terms
of the hazard of aspartame being linked
to cancer there is limited evidence and
it's not convincing and the second
aspect of the uh of the report assesses
risk and their assessment of risk is
that it remains at a very very low level
so the take-home message is that if
you're interested if you drink dice soft
drinks you can have one or two a day
because there's a wide safety limit in
that you can consume 40 milligrams per
kilogram of body weight and that relates
to about 15 cans of diet drinks per day
so there's a wide range of safety built
into the recommendation okay let's go
into energy drinks the Canadian food
inspection agency is recalling several
of them over caffeine levels including
Prime energy what's your reaction to the
Prime energy drinks being banned and
your advice to parents
I think this is a prudent move by Health
Canada to look at the recall of these
energy drinks they far exceed their
current recommendations in terms of
caffeine intake in adults and children
the energy drinks to my knowledge
contain up to about 200 milligrams per
beverage and in terms of children they
can be consuming safely up to about 150
milligrams and so the drinks themselves
may cause potential harm and lead to
dizziness convulsion and maybe a trip to
the emergency room if consumed in excess
what are some healthier alternatives to
energy drinks
great question uh so Health Canada has
the Canada's food guide and its
recommendation is to choose water as the
beverage of choice a second
recommendation is simply to cut back on
the consumption of these energy drinks
there are also other fun choices as well
carbonated drinks with with natural
flavoring and then also milk which is
high in calcium vitamin D good for the
bone and we get our sunshine vitamin and
100 orange juice not from concentrate so
there are definitely some fun options
out there for parents to choose as we
talk about healthier Alternatives back
to the other end of the spectrum and
aspartame which is again listed as a
possible carcinogen do you think there
are other foods and drinks more
concerning and overlooked like red meat
or alcohol
so very good question so that relates to
the level of Hazard and alcohol and is
certainly on the upper end of that
Spectrum much more so than than
aspartame a very good message to convey
is that we should think about the whole
diet are we getting enough fruits and
vegetables whole grains lean meats and
other lifestyle factors such as physical
activity and sleep as part of a healthy
lifestyle and and then Above All Above
All Else have fun and enjoy eating food
that is great advice David Maul from the
University of Guelph thank you very much
putting a new spin on things next how
humans are altering the Earth's axis
three two one zero
and with that India seeks to advance its
position as a major player in space this
rocket is headed to the moon's South
Pole it's expected to arrive next month
if the mission succeeds the rocket would
be the first to land at the lunar South
Pole which is of special interest to
space agencies due to the presence of
ice that could support a future Space
Station
back here on Earth there's new Research
into the incredible and unexpected
impacts humans are having on the planet
scientists have discovered Earth's Tilt
is actually shifting because of the huge
amount of water being used for farming
and drinking as Jackson prosco explains
the planet's wandering axis could have
unintended consequences
these days our world is a little
off-kilter
thanks to our insatiable thirst for
water
pump from sources deep underground if
you move water around on the planet from
one location to another you change its
angular momentum humans have extracted
trillions of tons of groundwater for
farming and drinking so much water that
scientists say it has shifted the tilt
of the entire planet moving the rotation
Axis or North Pole although we can't see
the axis the Earth still turns or
rotates around it when groundwater is
pumped and used at the surface it
eventually Finds Its way into the oceans
adding to sea level rise and as the
planet spins at 1600 kilometers per hour
all that extra water sloshes around in
its new location it weighs so much that
it is Shifting Earth's axis at a rate of
4.36 centimeters per year like an
overloaded washing machine the planet is
wobbling I think the lesson for us is
that the to be more proactive than
reactive and fight to minimize the human
footprint on the air because who knows
what's going to happen in 10 years 20
years time though the axis has been
known to move slightly with the seasons
the man-made shift has only recently
been understood but everybody that uses
navigation systems like the global
positioning system it's essential to
know exactly where that rotation axis is
and as the planet keeps on spinning it's
sending warning signs about our use of
limited groundwater
climate change is adding to the Tilt by
melting glaciers and ice caps raising
sea levels further there is deep
uncertainty on how we are impacting the
air system no one expects the wobble to
have a drastic impact on the seasons or
our long trip around the Sun but in
watching the world turn
scientists have tapped into a better
understanding of our incredible impact
on the planet
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
interesting that is global national for
this Friday night I'm nitu Garcia
tonight's your Canada is this Fawn and
dough in Winnipeg's Assiniboine Forest
we love seeing your Canada please email
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching pharah Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great
weekend
[Music]
thank you